obtenir un rendez vous avec un
ostéopathe en 48 heures c'est
l'engagement de ce nouveau cabinet
installé à elancourt ils sont quatre
professionnels à proposer cette prise en
charge dans le cadre d'une urgence une
nécessité pour marquer ma soto et ses
patients qui devait attendre parfois
plusieurs semaines
ça permet une réponse supplémentaire à
une demande de soin soulager le patient
rapidement pour éviter que la pathologie
s'installe et que d'autres zones du
corps soient impactés soit en
dysfonctionnement
cette ancienne maison médicale à
l'abandon a été entièrement rénové un
chantier financé personnellement par les
six associés du projet trois mois de
travaux cinq salles de soins et une
décoration épurée
ouvert depuis le mois de mai le nouveau
cabinet fait déjà l'unanimité
on a ici un cadre où on est vraiment au
calme un cadre un peu privilégié des
locaux tout neufs et on a hâte des plus
grandes salles avec plus d espace donc
pour les patients je pense que l'accueil
est meilleur dès qu'on a un blocage le
matin c'est vrai que quand on appelle
directement au centre on a un rendez
vous rapidement dans la journée et c'est
vrai que
c'est vraiment l'idéal en fait pour ceux
qui travaillent et ceux qui travaillent
pas aussi c'est très propre
c'est très clair c'est très zen très
calme a surtout et quand on est en soin
ça c'est vraiment appréciable
l'ostéopathie est une médecine reconnu
par l'état comme une profession à part
entière depuis 2002 en dehors des
urgences le cabinet fonctionne aussi sur
rendez vous plus classique de 9h à 20h30
en semaine